demacrado pero aparentemente de buen
humor el crítico del kremlin alexéi
navalni compareció ante el tribunal el
jueves por videollamada su primera
aparición desde que puso fin a su huelga
de hambre de 24 días la audiencia de
apelación fue contra el veredicto que le
imputa cargos de difamación de un
veterano de la segunda guerra mundial
algo que nada ni sigue rechazando
[Música]
todo este caso es una falsificación
incluso las firmas fueron falsificadas
usted señoría lo sabe muy bien y por eso
no concedió la petición de verificar las
firmas probablemente es una nueva norma
de la justicia rusa
los abogados del opositor encarcelado
afirman que el tiempo en prisión ha
tenido graves efectos sobre su salud
pero aseguran que la situación podría
haber sido aún peor si no hubiese apoyo
público si no hubiesen numerosas quejas
no habría recibido ninguna asistencia
médica como no la recibió durante mucho
tiempo la comparecencia de navalny se da
mientras las autoridades intentan
diezmar a la oposición con nuevos
métodos el equipo de naval de iu decidió
cerrar las oficinas de campañas
regionales después de que los fiscales
presentarán una solicitud para calificar
a la organización política de naval ni
como extremista por un lado el uno el
rey ha muerto larga vida al rey
todo nuestro tedioso trabajo en los
últimos cuatro años y vuestro apoyo no
han sido en vano hemos plantado las
semillas de la libertad en rusia que
florecerán para regar esto al xxi naval
ni sigue cumpliendo una condena de dos
años y medio por violar la libertad
condicional de una condena anterior por
malversación de fondos